[Music]
welcome to session 67 in the worlds of
speculative fiction series this time
around we are going to be looking at
these four books and I don't say four
novels because two of these are actually
collections of short stories in The
Witcher series by Andres sapkowski so
we're looking at the Last Wish and sort
of Destiny both of which are short story
collections there's a little bit of
confusingness you could say in how these
come out and then we're looking at the
first two of the novels in the sequence
the blood of elves and time of contempt
and you might say why aren't you doing
the whole series well we'll put off the
other books until later on because this
is already a lot of content to go
through in a you know roughly 90 to 100
minute video so worlds of speculative
fiction is this series that we've been
doing since
2016 and started out as a face-to-face
sort of gathering to discuss interesting
narrative worlds spanning multiple books
by classic and contemporary authors in
speculative fiction fantasy sci-fi
horror among others and every year I
would do a give me some suggestions and
then take the best suggestions put them
into a poll and sapkowski was actually a
winner not this last year but the
previous obvious year we did the poll in
2021 and this is a fan favorite and I
just didn't get to it by the end of 2022
in the sessions that we did do so I said
well we'll do this early in 2023 and I
got my hands on you notice that these
are a little bit mismatched right these
two are volumes that I bought at our
look local Half Price Books and then
these are from the great Milwaukee
Library system and I started reading my
way through these two
and I was very pleasantly surprised
because you know when it comes to Fan
choices you never know if it's going to
be great stuff or not so great stuff and
this is indeed great fantasy fiction
there's so much going on in it uh very
cool character development interesting
ethical Dimensions that get explored the
nature of magic evil goodness human
motives and all sketched on this
continent with lots of moving pieces you
could say indeed a continent for which
there is no definitive map as we'll also
talk about so
um we're going to go through the stories
and the World building some of the
characters some of the plots some of the
cool philosophical themes we'll also
talk about the biography of sapkowski as
a living writer and you know where these
books originated from and how they
became the excellent series that they
they are in literature and also uh
adapted to
um some some you know we could call it
the big screen but it's actually
streaming video of a show as well so
settle in we got some cool fantasy to
discuss let's jump right away into
giving you a little bit of a tidbit of
the world that uh The Witcher and the
other important characters Jennifer
dandelions Siri also inhabits
since this is Worlds of speculative
fiction we should talk about World
building and the setting for all of
these great short stories and novels and
just in this half of what we can call
The Witcher Saga up until this point and
I think it's useful to begin at the
start with a comparison to somebody that
sapkowski often gets likened to and that
is J.R.R Tolkien and I think we could
also bring in some comparison to George
R Martin and to Ursula Kayla green and
to our Scott backer in this respect and
I'm you know there's many others we
could talk about these are the ones that
come to mind for me so why talk about
Tolkien
so Tolkien by contrast to George R
Martin who you know talks about this in
interviews is often likened to be an
architect he has not only maps of all of
Middle Earth set out that he has created
himself he has developed the cultures
and their back histories and even their
languages that they're going to be using
George R Martin contrasted himself with
you know for example The Song of Ice and
Fire against Tolkien by saying I'm a
gardener I plant seeds and then I see
how they grow and I nurture them
actually he kills off a lot of his seeds
as well quite notoriously right and so
I'm not an architect like Tolkien who
has you know the world more or less you
know figured out and there's not a lot
of like Revelation along the way
um and you know this got Martin into a
bit of a pickle apparently that's part
of why Song of Ice and Fire is so hard
to
finish up he says that he plotted
himself into some Corners
um we might also think about our Scott
backer you know talking about fantasy
novels and his second apocalypse you
know lots and lots of World building
going on and actually getting play
tested in D and D games for you know
over a decade really about two decades
before he starts developing his first
novel and then you know bringing them
out in succession and of course there's
new things that come about you know
exploring different territories
different lands that had been just
mentioned or on the map you know
previously in later books but you know
he's more of an architect in some ways
now what could we call
if George R Martin is a Gardener by his
own lights well then sapkowski would be
a super Gardener there isn't even a map
of the territory rather the continent
other people create maps and then you
know sapkowski will sometimes weigh in
and say yeah that looks pretty good you
know great you know but he didn't make a
map for himself and as we're going to
see when we look at interviews there's a
lot of like things just kind of
developing you know if Martin is a
gardener who plants seeds Sakowski is
the kind of gardener like myself in
previous times who pirated plants who
would go and wander around and see
something you know like an interesting
kind of blackberry bush and be like Oh
I'm taking that that's coming back and
I'll put it in my garden you know and
doing things along those lines me making
prairies just scattering seeds all over
the place not carefully planting them
and in a certain way I brought up Ursula
Kayla Queen
in a certain way according to her what
she did with Earthsea is similar now of
course she did have a map and in her
interviews she says quite famously I had
to write further stories because I
wasn't sure what who lived in that part
and what was going on in that portion of
the map so I wrote the story so I could
fill it in for myself this is different
the stories are driving the mapping and
the history of this this continent
it's kind of hazy you know it's there's
a lot of well you know people say that
this happened and clearly there have
been some things that that took place
but are they exactly like the the
stories that are being told no not not
really and so you know there is a map
and I'm I'm going to be linking to um
one of the or maybe multiple better maps
in the video description here and I just
want to talk about what we actually have
and I'm I'm actually looking at one of
the maps right now so we have this
continent and it's you know it's it's a
decently
enclosed space with lots of varied
cultures and monsters and humanoid races
that are often at odds with each other
um some of whom are pursuing Conquest
some of whom just want to be left alone
and it's you know in sapowski's
descriptions it's a pretty well
developed world where it needs to be
there's a lot going on within this
narrative universe so we have you know
in the South there's uh we could call it
an evil empire if we want certainly
expansionist it's one of the states
nilfgaard that is now moving North
conquering territories along the way you
know sort of like an imperialist Rome or
uh something else along those lines and
then we have all of these Northern
countries and there's there's borders
there's mountain borders right in the
very North you have the dragon mountains
and you know later on we find out that
there are people who live beyond the
dragon mountains Dragon mountains
because there's you know white dragons
up there in in the ice
um but they speak you know different
languages and they don't play a big role
certainly not in the uh early for books
and then we have other mountain ranges
to the east
the Blue Mountains the fiery mountains
you know the others in in the South
um
there we go the uh yeah the ones down in
in nilfgaard and these essentially
border and block off this part of the
continent from the desert wastes further
east right so you can go in there there
are peoples there are cultures there are
even kingdoms there's trade going on but
for the most part you kind of stay out
of that area so we got you know the
southern kingdoms the northern kingdoms
nilfgaard dominating the South and then
we have this vast Sea called the Great
Sea and there's also a North Sea further
north and there's islands called Uh
skelliga there's other Islands as well
including one which is particularly
associated with uh sorcery and and
studying uh you know magic which is
quite important
um and you know there's all sorts of
other things going on as well there's
there's peninsulas uh it's quite an
interesting
venue and then then you know you go
further north you start getting into all
these different kingdoms so I'm just
going to run through these these names
Corvair and pulvis uh the Hang fours
League
um
you know the uh Kingdom of uh Adrian
tamaria lyria Rivia rivia's where geralt
is is from right verden Centra Centra is
going to play a major role sodden major
battles going on there uh and then
there's you know all sorts of other
things Dole angra and there's forests
and there's marshes and so you know
you've got the sort of typical fantasy
setting now one of the things that we
have to talk about besides this
north-south struggle right you've got
these Kingdoms in the north and they're
disunited sometimes fighting with each
other uh jealous of their prerogatives
and you got Wizards and and you know uh
Mages and other magic users floating
around including witchers right and then
you've got you know various religious
cults uh playing roles as well but
the continent is people by all sorts of
I'd mentioned humanoid races so you know
there are elves there are dwarves there
are gnomes there are halflings there are
dryads you know and uh sometimes you
know even stranger creatures uh
doppelgangers who can change into you
know different forms and
it sounds like D and D doesn't it yeah
at that point
but there's some important differences
you know in Dungeons and Dragons these
were all character these were all Races
that could be played by people and then
they were bad races like you know
goblins and Orcs And Knolls and all that
right well in this world these different
races are you know sometimes cooperating
with each other sometimes getting along
and sometimes
at odds with each other the human beings
wound up in this area through something
called you know the conjunction of the
Spheres this cataclysm that that pushed
worlds together and like allowed
different
um races to to wind up within this world
and so you know first you've got
conflict between elves and dwarves and
gnomes and you know things kind of get
worked out the elves learn how to use
magic and and there's an elder speech
that's also connected with this and then
the human beings will arrive and there's
different waves of them and the human
beings really here's the long and short
of it with some exceptions the human
beings more or less push the other races
the older races into marginal areas into
ghettos and cities discriminate against
them sometimes engage in pogrom you know
eliminating them even to the point of
genocide and the other races you know
fight back very often or try to subvert
things and and yet at the same time
humans will also hire you know dwarves
to help them out with this or that or
gnomes to do you know do the accounts or
various things along those lines and we
get to see a lot of different
interesting cultures being developed in
part because we're seeing things in
large part Through The Eyes of geralt of
of Rivia or Geralds depending on how you
want to pronounce it and and somebody's
going to correct me but don't even
bother because it doesn't matter right
so
why do we get to see things through his
eyes
he's kind of an in-between character he
is a human who has been modified who's
been mutated his life and how they put
it through the use of not just various
kinds of magic but all sorts of herbs
and poisons and other things to change
him giving him eyes that can see in the
dark for example an incredible healing
capacity superhuman reflexes uh you know
the ability to use magic in certain ways
and he has bread in a terrible process
that ends up killing most of the people
most of the children who the witchers do
this with to become a Witcher that is to
become a hunter
of monsters and not all monsters you
know for example uh in one story geralt
is like yeah dragons I don't do that
buddy you know that's a different sort
of thing I I deal with an noxious
monsters that prey on human beings and
perhaps even some of the other races as
well and so he's not quite human
he's definitely not one of the other
races but he can you know be perceived
by them as
something other than human and so he can
go to places and travel with people who
otherwise would do him in now this
doesn't always get him out of everything
he runs into bands of elves who try to
you know Rob him kill him things like
that but we're we're able to learn a lot
more about this world through his eyes
and so that's the setting that we've got
and we you know if you want to there's
this word grim dark that gets used to
talk about you know for example George
RR Martin's Song of Ice and Fire or our
Scott backers
um you know second apocalypse this is a
grim dark world it's not a world that
everything is bad in right by any means
there are many moments even eras of
understanding of development of Love of
companionship but there's also an awful
lot of suffering and conflict and pain
and loss and danger running throughout
this world as well so there's a lot of
interesting moral Reflections in the
book communicated by the characters or
thought of by the characters there's
growth that's going to happen and how
they view things but that is the setting
for us and we're going to learn a little
bit more about this as we look at the
interviews that sapkowski has given the
things that he said about his world
there isn't an awful lot of readily
available biographical information about
Andres sapkowski out there in part
because he's a bit reticent about
talking about his past except for in
interviews you know giving some
interesting details that more often have
to do with his work and less often with
his life as such there is a big origin
story that will narrate in just a bit
about him as the author of The Witcher
series but we should start at the start
so he's a Polish author born in lodes
and that's where his parents will end up
settling he's born in 1948 so shortly
after World War II during which his
father served in the Polish People's
Army which was on the Eastern side and
his father actually according to him
fought in the Battle of Berlin
um you know there's a very bloody time
and a lot of Reconstruction had to take
place throughout the areas where the
Soviet Union and you know Nazi Germany
and their allies had fought and Poland
was really at the heart of that so he
grows up in a Poland where things are
being rebuilt he also grows up in a
family of readers where there are many
many books there's not a ton of things
to do and reading is something that he
gets into quite a lot you know he goes
to high school and then is going to go
to university of Lords so he stays
basically in town and he studies
economics why does he study economics
it's considered a safe field and you
know safe field means not only you're
going to get a job but also it could
keep you out of trouble with the
political authorities as well and he
becomes a he does a lot of different
jobs eventually he becomes a sales
representative traveling around in
Poland but also to other countries
selling Furs and he does some marketing
and that's going to play a role as he
says in the success of The Witcher
series and The Story begins in 1985 and
it has to do with a contest that's being
held by this journal uh Fanta skia which
was you know quite popular and you know
it's interesting because there's a lot
of Reflections in interviews
about fantasy literature and whether
it's for children whether it's serious
or not and sapkowski decides his son uh
who is named Christoph is a reader of
this he decides I'm gonna enter
something now he had been writing
stories for quite some time so this
isn't his for first story ever
but it's the first story in The Witcher
sequence so he writes a story called The
Witcher in which geralt you know is the
point of your character and it's you
know found in the uh the you know the
books right in uh the very first of them
um and it's the the first story where
there's a redoing of uh a motif you
could say about the the vampire the
striga the the evil uh creature who it
turns out not to be quite so evil after
all if you're treating them the right
way but the right way isn't giving them
a kiss or anything it's actually
fighting them until dawn and keeping
them out of their Crypt so he he sends
this story in and
it wins it wins third place it doesn't
win first place and sapkowski says well
that's because they didn't think fantasy
was really that serious of a thing and
it's it catches on people like it and
readers are AVID for this and they're
like you should write some more stuff so
he does he starts writing more and more
and uh you know his his son is into that
as well he wins some awards the Giannis
uh zajil awards for short stories the
sort of Destiny the lesser of two evils
and so he's he's got a good you know
side gig going on you could say and he's
moving more and more towards becoming a
professional author away from doing
these jobs that are really just jobs not
his beloved career or anything like that
and he's he's getting to live the life
the as an author that he wants then in
1994 when you see the the publication of
Blood of Elves the first of the novels
the full novels about uh geralt of Rivia
and these other characters that are
going to be so important for example you
know uh Siri Tris Marigold the other two
characters that we've already been
introduced to is pretty important
dandelion and uh the love of geralt's
life yennefer so
these are quite important and you know
there were other houses out there that
were interested in it but it's this
Supernova that takes a chance they're
like you can write novels and
interestingly there weren't a lot of
fantasy
novels you know as zubkowski says in the
Anglo-Saxon world the English-speaking
world there's tons of fantasy stuff in
Poland ah not really right there's
translations of things but
people aren't writing these things for
the sake of writing them in Polish as
soon to be translated in many many other
languages as well and Blood of Elves
wins the David Guetta Legend award
um it starts to get you know his works
are translated into many other languages
including English he's already got a
massive following in Poland and some of
the closer countries and then he starts
impacting the English-speaking world as
well and he continues writing novels set
in that same narrative Universe all the
way up to Lady of the Lake in
1999. so there's a well-developed body
of let's call it uh you could you could
call it Witcher geralt stuff but you
have to include all the other characters
who are involved in it as well
in the meantime he's going to do some
other things as well he creates a
role-playing game called eye of uridis
in 1995. he publishes uh an you know an
essay on the world of King Arthur and
then there's another thing that has me
fascinated it doesn't appear to be
translated at this point in time I would
love to be able to read it in the
original or get my hands on a
translation manuscript discovered in a
Dragon's Cave published in
2001 and what is this this is an essay a
book length essay on fantasy literature
looking at of course you know J.R
Tolkien but people all the way up to
George RR Martin so you know he's he's
very cognizant about what's going on you
could say in this genre he will turn his
attention away a from The Witcher and
into other things The hussite Saga Tower
of fools in 2002 Warriors of God in 2004
light Perpetual in 2006 uh you know set
explicitly in Central Europe he writes
another novel a standalone called Viper
which is situated in the Soviet Afghan
war he publishes that in 2009 and of
course gives many many interviews uh
throughout really down to the the
present I should mention that the
Witcher Saga spun off a vast amount of
other media including comic books that
began getting published in the 1990s in
1993 to 1995 there was also a Dark Horse
Series which was not based on
sapkowski's stories apparently but
others polish TV created a Witcher
series back in 2000 and one which also
led to a movie there's of course the
Netflix series which is still going on
right now and there's a little bit of
controversy about that
um sapkowski himself says well I just
advise I don't tell people what to do
um
there was a role-playing video game put
out by CD projekt Red and you know other
Witcher based games and subkowski
himself has sueds at least one of the
game things for a contract in which he
thought he got the short end of the deal
I should mention as well that The
Witcher has resulted in some musical
things as well 2009 the Russian heavy
metal band Essa brought out a rock opera
based on The Witcher and in 2017 the
musical theater of gadinha brought out a
musical based on it as well so there's a
number of different
reinterpretations that people are making
of these very very interesting dark
reflective
captivating
works that Sakowski has brought into
being it doesn't appear that he has any
plans to add to the Witcher Universe
with news stories or novels but he is
still for an author relatively young in
his 70s so who knows what we'll see on
the horizon as it stands he produced
eight great books of The Witcher series
and as I mentioned many other great
books as well we're focusing primarily
on The Witcher stuff so that's where the
center of attention lies that's probably
enough about his bio for the present
so sapowski has been interviewed many
times not just because of his Witcher
books but also because of the television
shows the games you know he goes to
various conventions talks with people
and he has a lot of interesting things
to say about his own world the
characters the processes some of the
points that he wants to make you can
also tell when you read the interviews
that he's not a jaded person but he's
not an optimist and he is very willing
to be blunt about things which I I quite
like and he's also influenced by some
other authors you could say who adopt
you know similar perspectives so in the
wired interview he's asked what is the
secret that makes geralt of Rivia such a
fan favorite character
so he says when I created him in the
first story to submit him to a fantasy
fiction competition in Poland I had only
one choice before me do it well or do
not or not do it at all for me the story
of a book is like the Marquee of a
circus the protagonist is the pole that
supports it and the secondary characters
are the pegs that keep it anchored to
the ground all of this must be built in
the best possible way so as not to
collapse under its own weight and then I
wonder what moves the protagonist and
the answer is obvious a woman then we're
going to talk more about women in a bit
um that's a very interesting metaphor
isn't it a circus a tadpole pegs a
marquee that is uh bringing things off
so he says speaking of women in your
books
um the female characters are almost
always stronger and more determined than
the male ones and he says yeah sure
because that's how it is in real life
women are and always have been stronger
than men now isn't that an interesting
thing to say and you know if you look
into your own memories you can probably
find many strong women many resourceful
women uh and then he's asked would you
define yourself as a feminist and he
says no I adore women I adore their role
in historian in the world but I don't
make a philosophy out of it and you know
we could say similar things about his
attitudes towards races and exploitation
domination colonization uh genocide he
doesn't make a philosophy out of it
there are a few places where characters
in the books will have Reflections about
you know how terrible this particular
thing is and why can't we get along
but sapkowski isn't going to tip his
hand and say yes I'm I'm telling a story
that has these definite themes now
here's another interesting follow-up in
that same interview the geralt of the
books always tries to stay out of
politics only to fail miserably does he
think that fantasy plays a similar
similar role that it wants to be as many
argue a form of escapism to forget the
problems of the real world
and sapkowski says
many try to frame fantasy to Define it
as escapism but it's not like that with
the Lord of the Rings Tolkien certainly
wasn't trying to escape from The Real
World those who seek escapism are
welcome but that's not the aim of a
fantasy author
and maybe we need to modify this and say
well it's not the theme of a great
fantasy author uh but it could be the
theme of you know
second rate fantasy authors sapkowski
was able to see the the sort of
blossoming and burgeoning of the fantasy
landscape in Book Sales and and what was
available in books in the 70s and in the
80s as he traveled
we have another interview here with
Christian Handel who says as the author
of The Witcher Saga what is it you like
most about geralt and supkowski says
he's a fictional character created to
serve the story which revolves around
him again we see the sort of you know
tent pole right
if the fictional character serves the
story well an author likes his character
if an author doesn't like his character
finds him unlikable or faulty in any
part or aspect it means an author has
done his job poorly or he's
schizophrenic or both
so that's a very you know telling
observation the characters belong to the
author the author is responsible for the
characters being compelling characters
uh he goes on as as well and uh he's
asked uh there's a lot of novels which
people love but are forgotten over time
some maintain their significance over
time why do you think the Witcher Saga
has remained so popular and so sapkowski
says well and he uses this in many
interviews very true is the proverb
haben suafata libeli or books have their
own Destinies the rest is silence so
he's not going to prognosticate about
you know why the books are successful
and then he's asked again which part of
your fantasy world do you like most and
why and he says my fantasy world was
created to serve the story look above
the answer to question one character
world are serving story and the the work
of story telling
now here's where we get to the World
building
how much did you know about that world
and its characters when you first
started to write about them and how long
did it take you to create such an epic
setting
owski nothing at all don't forget I
began with short stories you don't
create universes and short stories there
is literally and metaphorically no place
for them later when my stories started
evolving into full novels the necessity
of some coherent background became
imminent and slowly step by step
something resembling a universe began to
emerge but it's only in the background
so it plays a secondary role in the
story
now shifting he's asked your short story
seem to draw heavily from folklore and
fairy tales why did you decide to play
with these motifs in your writing and so
sapkowski then says well one of the
sub-genres of the fantasy genre there
are several of them is called the
retelling which consists of taking
classic fairy tales fables Legends or
myths and telling them Anew whether
changed modified sometimes even
distorted or Twisted in perverse ways I
I just use the classic technique
and um
then he's asked it shifts again back to
short stories The Witcher Saga started
with short stories in your opinion what
are the advantages of short stories
Sakowski says and notice who he's
referencing here Isaac Asimov used to
say a short story is a straight line a
novel is a plane in the story the writer
and the reader goes straight from point
A to point B in the novel you move in
many directions both have their
advantages and disadvantages depending
on what an author or reader likes or
dislikes and then he's asked again well
why did you expand The Witcher Saga into
a series of full-length novels and he
says once again notice he's got this
tendency if I've already said something
why do I have to repeat myself Isaac
Asimov straight line in plain for me it
was a natural consequence at some point
I I felt tied up and limited by the size
of a short story or Novella and desired
to abandon the line and ride the what
the wide plane I will say though so you
know Blood of Elves uh time of content a
discon uh contempt rather so these two
um uh the last witch wish and sort of
Destiny short stories right and they're
episodic
you could look at these these novels as
also being bundles of short stories that
all actually fit together depending on
which point of view we're looking at so
you know
that's kind of interesting and then
here's the last thing from that
interview if you could invite two
fictional or historical characters for a
dinner party who would you choose and
why
so notice who he says he doesn't say
Tolkien
he says Ernest Hemingway
and Umberto Echo I consider them the
best writers of all time now this is
very interesting you know Hemingway not
known for Fantasy known for a kind of
realism a pair down realism and a you
know simplistic way of writing uh
deceptively simplistic and then Umberto
Echo who's quite uh florid brings all
sorts of theory in as a matter of fact
when you read echo's novels and you also
read Echoes you know Theory books you
see him plagiarizing himself constantly
in the novels which you know maybe
that's a good way of writing
um there's also a great uh uh font
fantasy Mundo you know fantasy world
interview
and here we get to a different uh topic
they ask him in your stories you take
the part of the losers and the
defenseless does this owe to a certain
social justice from this it's not common
to encounter in fantasy so demoralizing
and terrible in its message is yours
were you conscious of this are you a
natural
demythizer when you wrote the books of
geralt of Rivia can one assume an
analogy with different author Raymond
Chandler
and then Sakowski says yep you have
Nailed It Gerald has much in common with
Philip Marlow he is a cynic no one will
deny that all writers we are doubters of
our previous readings nor that we are
intelligent and we have a blank check to
do what we want we make ourselves more
intelligent when we speak than the rest
when we want a woman or we hate another
person
I am the result of my readings of
Alexander Dumas Henrik senkiewicz
Raymond Chandler Roger zelazny Jack
Vance Jules Verne Arturo Perez Rivera
they have created me as a writer again
notice who's not in there Ernest
Hemingway Roberto Echo these are the
people who he says uh
spurred him influenced him shaped him
the most and he says this is now what's
had what's passing with me there are
many that use me as a writer and in who
I influenced there are things that are
implanted in the brain of someone when
they write I am now in others and it is
normal the same as Chandler is in me I
do not believe Chandler would be
offended by this since I'm only
transferring the book to the book the
same cynicism he used but in place of
the dark Streets of San Francisco to the
mallow orderus streets of some place
which has never existed and never will
exist it is absolutely the same and
people like it of course don't forget
that when I began 13 years ago all the
world in Poland was absolutely sick of
superhero stories and they wanted a
story of a person who was not omnipotent
I receive many letters and emails
questioning why geralt is so weak but I
know that they want it too
and fantasy Mundo goes on do you believe
that time could convert the world of
geralt the Rivia into one of the great
sagas of fantasy literature so you know
is this going to be like the Lord of the
Rings and the Cimarron the Middle Earth
is this going to be like Earthsea is
this going to be like to take Rogers
lazny Amber chaos and all the other
things in between so sapkowski says to
respond to that to say that the Saga is
going to end up being one of the great
ones of fantasy would be immodest on my
part of course I've done what I have
been able to do in Poland I placed the
first stone certainly and now there are
more authors that are learning to do the
same
perhaps after my death which could be
near some critics will place me on that
list of the best of fantasy like David
Pringle did in his 100 best books of
fantasy where all of them are
Anglo-Saxons except for Patrick suskind
and his perfume and Michael Enda and the
never-ending story many critics have
said to my face we don't like Eskimos
writing about zebras and now they are
the zebras time will tell
um then there's a shift in perspective
and this goes to some of the key
characters and their their relationships
seeing the triangle which geralt
Jennifer and Siri form I couldn't avoid
seeing in them the sketch of the
traditional western family had you
already a preconception of a
pseudo-familial development for these
characters or did the idea emerge little
by little and I think there's a lot of
other people who see that as well you
know Siri is this younger child and
geralt has you know they're involved
because of deaths that Andrew Roth is
also involved with the anifer and uh
Siri uh you know is got an attachment to
Jennifer Triss also plays an important
role until she of course passes away at
this great battle in sodden but there's
other things going on as well are they
really a nuclear family so sapkowski
says the first thing I did was fight
against The Stereotype to present the
typical hero who seeks a reward who
saves the world the World Trade Center
Tel Aviv who has all the women he wants
I've altered the myth this is a hero
which says don't screw with me don't
bother me anymore to place this hero in
front of different situations such as a
woman who also departs from the
stereotypes could be very harsh but also
very interesting look for the look to
the woman right
and they go on as well
fantasy Mundo says are these characters
based on any real life models and he
says not a single one of them is based
on real people I'm very strict with this
and I want you to believe they all came
from my imagination I've never intended
to make a caricature of someone nor to
laugh at someone nor to demonstrate I
dislike someone my readers don't give a
who I hate I cannot hate anyone
when I write though of truth yes I
dislike people but would never be so
arrogant as to show this to my readers
these are not allegories in in another
way of of speaking right
um
so he then there they asked judging by
the apocalyptic tone which presides over
your books I have the impression that
you are in truth about a clash of
civilizations and sapkowski says
that's right my case is not so Extreme
as that of Tolkien he suffered a
heckatome from his Youth and he spoke of
pollution and poison Rivers what do we
mean a hecatum a massive sacrifice
Tolkien was in World War one one of the
bloodiest Wars you know in the recent
history
um and so he says I am now 60 years old
many of the living things which I've
known have disappeared animals plants
insects Crustaceans from what was there
when I was 10 years old already not
remaining it is a disaster and all
that's occurred in the scope of one
man's lifetime he's talking about the
anthropocene and the uh you know perhaps
great destruction of
diversity and you know animal and plant
and other life within our world that
we're running through so he says what
can happen here in 50 years
perhaps it will all disappear and the
world will be reduced to ashes thinking
of it terrifies me
in another interview with lit Hub he's
asked about World building again and
this time it's about
mythologies and creatures he says what
kind of Mythology did you draw on to
create the world of The Witcher and
sokowski says well it would be easier to
name the mythologies and cultures I
didn't draw on because there were just
to mention a few Slavic mythology
vampires lashes kikmoras vodagnos there
was a Germanic wild Hunt the Portuguese
brusa the Arabic ghoul the Scottish
kilmulis there were dryads from Greek
myths paracelian gnomes the Japanese
kitsuni or foxwoman there was a little
mermaid that is Hans Christian Anderson
there was snow white by The Brothers
Grimm there was Jean-Marie LA Press de
beaumont's Beauty and the Beast elves
and dwarves are let's say tolkodesk you
could say it's quite an Eclectic
cocktail but that was the modus operandi
I adopted so he's you know bringing
together very very deliberately all
sorts of things into this fantasy world
he's also asked something very
interesting about the writing process
he's how do you tackle writer's block
and I love this answer
writer's block is overrated the term was
invented and established by lazy writers
who didn't feel like writing and needed
to find an excuse with agents and
Publishers the truth is there's always
some work to be done with a book even if
you don't feel like writing you can
correct what you've already written
Corrections never do any harm you can do
research study Source materials you can
read the competitors books not to steal
their ideas but to be familiar with
current trends and to find the right
course to steer among them
so very interesting Reflections there on
the craft of writing which for sapkowski
is this very unvarnished stuff there's
no like yes I am the great writer up in
the sky coming down to you with ideas
it's this is a job elsewhere he's
actually uh talked about the difference
between Craftsmen and uh you know really
good writers and he says yeah the kind
of stuff that I do I I'm an artist you
know so he's brutally honest about his
own talents but he he doesn't project
vanity in any respect the last interview
that I want to bring up is from io9 and
he says um when you were first
approached about doing a show adaptation
of The Witcher books how did you feel
about it did you have any reservations
sapkowski says well I must confess I was
reluctant at first I've been approached
before by many people mostly far from
being serious so I practically lost hope
and was difficult to persuade when
suddenly another offer appeared but the
specific offer was business-like and the
people behind it sympathetic I had every
reason to react positively
and then he's asked was there anything
you insisted be included or fought for
in in the show The Witcher series with
Netflix he means
says for the record I strongly believe
in the freedom of an artist in his
artistic expression I do not interfere
with and do not impose my views on other
artists I do not insist on anything and
I do not fight for anything I advise
when necessary and asked for
so he's content to let other people work
with the series that he's developed and
if you actually do watch The Witcher
series you will recognize many of the
stories from these interwoven in there
and then there's important changes as
well there's places just as with the
adaptation of The Lord of the Rings to
the movies you can be like well this
didn't happen this way right and you can
say a similar thing about that we could
say much more about George R Martin's uh
the Game of Thrones TV show which is
progressively worse the more it deviated
from the books
sapkowski is saying you know I'm going
to let artists be artists and there's a
certain kind of artistry in adapting
something to a different setting I'm not
a TV producer I'm not a for that matter
video game developer so what they do
with this Source material that I provide
them with I can have opinions about it I
can advise them but I'm not going to
dictate to them the way it has to go
because that's their business as artists
as we could say interpreters and I
actually find that quite refreshing so I
think these are some useful interviews
that give you a better idea of what's
going on with these characters House of
Kowski is developing them what's going
through his mind and his General
approach to Fantasy literature and to
his sources acknowledging the other
writers that have contributed to who he
is and what this series looks like
we've reached the point in our session
where we're going to be spending a lot
of time digging around in the books and
I think that sends sapkowski has framed
Gerald as the main character around
which the stories understandably The
Witcher stories are oriented as the poll
that is holding the circus tent up and
the other characters as 10 pegs maybe we
should begin with him I should say
however that as we move from the short
stories into the novels we see that
point of view will change and Siri will
be you know a point of view character
quite a bit uh Tris Marigold will
already in Blood of Elves and you know
there's also yennefer and um dandelion
and they're not minor characters by any
stretch as a matter of fact by the end
of a time of contempt I think you can
say that not only has Jennifer become
massively important as a character and
we're getting to see more and more of
her points of view but Siri is really
becoming incredibly important as a
matter of fact the this novel ends
essentially with a lot of
action and character development and
decisions on her part but we'll come
back to that in a bit so the stories
begin with this character The Witcher in
the very first you know one that we we
have here in the first book the voice of
reason and then they continue on and one
of the things that we see about geralt
is that there is
you know he he does have a a fixed
shaped character but there's some
development that's going on particularly
in response not just to falling in love
with with yennefer or you know hanging
out with the end of the lion who becomes
his his friend or caring about Siri but
um getting brought into the larger
picture of the conflicts that are
developing he wants to pose himself as
essentially just doing his job not
getting involved with other things he's
kind of you know not just kind of very
cynical about stuff but we're going to
see that change and I've selected a
number of passages where we get to see
him in conversation with other people
expressing what his point of view is we
could have selected many others but
let's just go through these and see what
what they reveal about this guy
so this is uh early on
um dandelion is having a discussion with
geralt and he says the world is changing
the sun sets vodka is coming to an end
what else in your opinion is coming to
an end you mentioned something about
endings philosopher and then geralt says
well I'll give you a couple of examples
all from two months of this side of the
Buena one day I ride up and what do I
see a bridge and under that bridge sits
a troll and demands every passerby pay
him those who refuse have a leg injured
sometimes both so I go to the alderman
how much are you going to give me for
that Troll And he says he's amazed what
are you talking about who will repair
the bridge of the trolls not there he
repairs it regularly with the sweat of
his brow solid work first rate it's
cheaper to pay his toll so I ride on
what do I see a fork tail not very big
about four yards uh nose tip to tail tip
it's flying carrying a sheep in its
Talons I go to the Village how much will
you pay me for the fork Tale know the
peasants shout it's our Baron's youngest
daughter's favorite Dragon if a scale
Falls from its back the baron will burn
our Hamlet and skin us I ride out and
I'm getting hungry and hungry or ask
around for a work certainly it's there
but what work to catch a ruscola yeah
rascala for one man a nymph for another
a dryad for a third they've gone
completely mad the villagers are teeming
with girls but they want humanoids
another asked me to kill a mechopaterian
and bring him a bone from its hand
because crushed and poured into a soup
it cures impotence
and dandelion says you know well you
know if people are inclined to pay and
Gerald says I'm not going to kill
mekopterans nor any other harmless
creatures and then uh dandelion says
well you'll go hungry then unless you
change your line of work become a priest
you wouldn't be bad at it with all your
Scruples your morality your knowledge of
people and everything the fact you don't
believe in any Gods shouldn't be a
problem I don't know many priests who do
become a priest and stop feeling sorry
for yourself right and uh he says Doral
you remind me of an old fisherman who
towards the end of his life discovers
that fish stink in the breeze from the
sea makes your bones ache be consistent
talking and regretting won't get you
anywhere if I were to find the demand
for poetry I'd come to an end I'd hang
up my Loot and become a gardener I'd
grow roses right and then they go on and
they they talk about the world that is
is coming he says you witchers deprive
yourself of work slowly but surely the
better and more conscientiously you work
the less work there is for you
after all your goal is a world without
monsters a world which is peaceful and
safe a world where witchers are
unnecessary a paradox isn't it
so there's you know that's an important
thing to note there's a paradoxicality
to the very calling actually not just
calling but imposition upon geralt of
being a Witcher a little bit further on
he's riding with dandelion as well and
they're talking about you know
non-existent monsters and at first
people believing in them and then
um
dandelion says geralt monsters do exist
maybe not as many as before maybe they
don't lurk behind every tree in the
forest but they're there they exist so
how do you account for people inventing
ones then what's more believing in what
they invent uh what What's the deal with
that haven't you wondered why and he
says well I have and I do know why
people geralt says like to invent
monsters and monstrosities then they
seem less monstrous themselves when they
get blind drunk cheat steal beat their
wives starve an old woman when they kill
a trapped Fox with an ax or rid of the
last existing unicorn with arrows they
like to think that the Bane entering
cottages at Daybreak is more monstrous
than they are they feel better then they
find it easier to live
so you know what we see here is geralt
he knows from you know long experience
how bad people can be he also doesn't
he's not so jaded that he doesn't uh
sometimes welcome moments of goodness or
you know charity
camaraderie but he's just very realistic
about how human beings are and his
profession gives him some additional
insights that other people often lack in
the sort of Destiny
we find a discussion about Order and
Chaos that is involved and you know we
should remember too that magic involves
uh chaos so there's this uh discussion
that that's going on here
um and uh here we go The Witcher shrug
prices are going up one has to live as a
sorceress acquaintance of mine used to
say quite a selective approach very
practical I'd say but the root of it
root of it lies at the root of it lies
some idea geralt the conflict between
the forces of order and the forces of
chaos as a sorcerer acquaintance of mine
used to say I imagine that you carry out
your mission defending people from Evil
always and everywhere without
distinction you stand on a clearly
defined side of the Palisade right of
the wall and then Gerald says
uh the forces of order the forces of
chaos awfully High flown words borscht
you desperately want to position me on
one side of the Palisade in a conflict
which is generally thought to be
perennial begun long before us and will
endure long after we've gone on which
side now notice what he's asking here on
which side is the farrier shoeing horses
stand or our Inn Keeper hurrying here
with a cauldron of lamb what in your
opinion defines the border between Order
and Chaos
a very simple thing said three Jack
Dawes and looked at him straight in the
eye that which represents chaos is
Menace is the aggressive side well order
is the side being threatened and in need
of protection in need of a Defender
um so you know they they continue on and
Boris says I understand you're not keen
on being placed on either side you do
your job that is correct
but you cannot escape the conflict
between Chaos and Order although it was
your comparison you're not a farrier
I've seen you work you go down into a
dungeon among some ruins and come out
with a slaughtered basilisk there is
comrade a difference between shoeing
horses and killing basilisks you said if
the payment is fair you'll hurry to the
end of the world and dispatch the
monster you're asked to and then we get
a very interesting shift in the
conversation so just to sum up at this
point we've got this philosophical
conversation where do you fit in geralt
or you know you're clearly on the side
of order uh you're protecting all of us
from from chaos and then
borscht says let's say a fierce dragging
is wreaking havoc and then Gerald says
bad example you see right away you've
mixed up chaos in order because I do not
kill dragons and they without doubt
represent chaos
how so 3G actors licked his fingers well
I never after all among all monsters
dragons are probably the most beastial
the cruelest and fiercest the most
revolting of reptiles they attack people
breathe fire and carry off you know
virgins there's no shortage of tales
like that it can't be that you a Witcher
don't have a few dragons on your trophy
list and then he says I don't hunt
dragons geralt said dryly I had Fork
tales for sure and Draco lizards and
flying Drakes but not true dragons the
green the black or the red take note
please
and why
um well because there are other people
to handle that sort of thing and as we
find out he's actually speaking with the
dragon at the time a gold dragon but
that will come up later
um so geralt doesn't kill any sort of
monster whatsoever he's selective and
what he's doing
here we have another interesting uh
passage a little bit later
um there's this this discussion between
geralt and uh Gillen Stearn uh Gerald
says do you have a job for me if so tell
me what I'll think it over but if you
don't there's no sense wasting our
breath and they're talking about the the
the dragons as well and uh uh he Gail
and Stern says dorigay surpasses even
witchers with his whims he does not stop
at categorizing monsters into good and
bad he considers them all good he
defends his views with astonishing
obstinacy I truly would not be surprised
if something befell him and the fact he
joined us keeping such curious company
and then he says the company is strange
a Witcher crawling with Scruples like a
fox pelt with fleas a sorcerer spouting
druidic humbug about equilibrium in
nature the Silent Night borsche three
jackdaws and his escort from zirakania
where as generally as known sacrifices
are made before the image of a dragon
and suddenly they all join in the hunt
right so they have a uh they finish that
conversation and then dorigay comes over
and uh says
um
it's in you know it's it's quite
interesting the two of you have similar
occupations except that eck eck is this
sort of like noble Knight is an idealist
and you're a professional a minor
difference particularly for the ones you
kill then Gerald says don't compare me
to EK the devil knows who you wrong in
that comparison him or me but don't
compare us and then uh the sorcerer says
to me Witcher calling killing a vocation
is loathsome low and nonsensical our
world is in equilibrium the annihilation
the killing of any creatures that
inhabit this world upsets that
equilibrium and a lack of equilibrium
brings closer extinction extinction in
the end of the world as we know it and
then Gerald says yes that's a druidic
theory I know it an old hero font
expounded it to me once back in Rivia
two days after our conversation he was
torn apart by wear rats it was
impossible to prove any upset in
equilibrium
the world I repeat Oregon glanced at him
indifferently is in equilibrium natural
equilibrium every species has its own
natural enemies everyone is the natural
enemy of other species that also
includes humans the extermination of the
natural enemies of humans which you
dedicate yourself to and which one can
begin to observe threatens the
degeneration of the race
and then Gerald says do you know what
sorcerer one day take yourself to a
mother whose child has been devoured by
a basilisk tell her she ought to be glad
because thanks to that the human race
has escaped a generation see what she
says to you and then Jennifer rides up
and the conversation ends so what we
have here very interestingly now it's
not just order and chaos now it's like
an environmental equilibrium and keeping
the human race healthy and geralt is
being accused by his very work of making
things worse making things too easy for
the human beings and Exterminating other
species which he rejects in you know in
favor of saying uh you need to think
about how it is for the people who are
actually affected by these monsters
we noticed something else very
interesting in this book this
conversation between geralt and a
Doppler now a Doppler is a type of human
non-human humanoid that can take on
other people's
um not just their their appearances but
even their thoughts their ways of of
doing things and the Doppler is
um talking about what's what's going on
and what's been going on for a long time
another big philosophical theme that
we'll we'll get to exploitation
domination genocide so he says I'm going
to go on my way Witcher squeeze my way
into the crowd and change quietly into
any old person even a beggar because I
prefer being a beggar a navagrad to
being a Doppler in the woods navagrad
owes me something geralt the building of
a city here tainted a land we could have
lived it lived in our natural form we
have been exterminated hunted down like
rabid dogs I'm one of the few to survive
I want to survive and I will survive
long ago when wolves pursued me in the
winter I turned into a wolf and ran with
the pack for several weeks and I
survived now I'll do that again because
I don't want to roam about through
wildernesses and be forced to Winter
beneath Fallen trees I don't want to be
forever hungry I don't want to serve as
target practice all the time here in
navagrad it's warm there's grub I can
make money and very seldom to people
shoot arrows at each other navagrad is a
pack of wolves I'll join that pack and
survive understand
reluctantly
you gave dwarves halflings gnomes and
even elves the Doppler can continued
the modest possibility of assimilation
why should I be any worse off why am I
denied that right why do I have to what
do I have to do to be able to live in
this city turn into a shield with doe
eyes silky hair and Long Legs well in
what way is a shelf better than me only
at the site of the shield you pick up
speed and at the sight of me you want to
puke you know where you can stuff an
argument like that I'll survive anyway
The Witcher said nothing yes I said
teleco continued calmly I'm going and
you this is the part that we want to pay
particularly close attention to you
jeralt will not even try to stop me
because I drew out knew your thoughts
for a moment including the ones you
don't want to admit to the ones you even
hide from yourself because to stop me
you'd have to kill me and the thought of
Killing Me In Cold Blood fills you with
disgust doesn't it
The Witcher said nothing
farewell Gerald he said thank you
farewell Dudu The Witcher replied good
luck so he doesn't just
concede it to him he actually says good
luck
geralt is you know as he's a person with
Scruples as he's been talked about
before he thinks about these matters
even though he is a you know definitely
Man of Action uh one last discussion
from from this book that I think is kind
of interesting
dandelion is saying this to Gerald and
actually we you know we learned a lot
about geralt by reflection through what
other characters have to say about him
whether it's correct or incorrect
dandelion knows geralt pretty well
they're they're close friends and he you
know he composes uh songs about him so
he has to do a good bit of thinking
about that
the end of lion says do you know what
your problem is geralt you think you're
different
you flaunt your otherness what you
consider abnormal you aggressively
impose that abnormality on others not
understanding that for people who think
clear-headedly you're the most normal
man under the sun
and they uh and they all wish that
everybody was so normal what of it that
you have quicker reflexes than most and
vertical pupils and sunlight that you
can see in the dark like a cat that you
know a few spells big deal I my dear
once knew an Innkeeper who could fart
for 10 minutes without stopping playing
the tune to the psalm greet us greet us
o Morningstar heedless of his let's face
it unusual Talent The Innkeeper was the
most normal among the normal he had a
wife children and a grandmother
afflicted by palsy
what does that have to do with Essie
Davin could you explain Gerald says of
course you wrongfully thought Gerald
that little I was interested in you out
of morbid downright perverted curiosity
that she looks at you as if you were a
queer fish a two-headed calf or a
salamander in a menagerie and you
immediately became annoyed gave her a
rude undeserved reprimand at the first
opportunity struck back a blow she
hadn't dealt I witnessed it after all I
didn't witness the further course of
events but what I noticed your flight
from the room and saw her glowing cheeks
when you returned yes geralt I'm
alerting you to a mistake and you've
already made it you wanted to take
revenge on her for in your opinion her
morbid curiosity
you tried to learn whether it was
possible to Better In the hey if she was
curious to find out what it's like to
make love with a misfit a Witcher
fortunately Essie turned out to be
smarter than you and generously took
pity on your stupidity having understood
its cause right and then he goes out and
he says do you really not prefer normal
girls like Essie what a sorceresses have
that Essie doesn't age perhaps little
little I may not be the youngest but
she's as old as she looks and you know
what Jennifer once confessed to me after
a few stiff drinks she told me the first
time she did it with a man it was
exactly a year after the invention of
the twofero pro plow right so he's very
very old and what does this conversation
reveal to us well you know The Witcher
draw is he's a a misfit he's a mutant
he's been modified from the normal human
condition he feels alienated he doesn't
fit in he goes from place to place where
people in general know where they fit in
the social order and he comes in as an
intruder and he projects outward
the idea that everyone is looking at him
as if he's the weirdo the person who
doesn't really belong and in some cases
like dandelion says he really is just a
normal person who happens to have
uncanny abilities
In The Blood of Elves the first novel
we see
geralt talking with uh Tris and vessimer
and they're discussing what they're
going to do in terms of uh the council
and War and all that so Tris says war is
constantly hovering over us like a
vulture for you it's an adventure for me
it's a game in which the stakes are
survival I'm involved in this game
that's why you're indifference and
frivolity hurt and insult me and Gerald
says we're witchers Tris can't you
understand that
what's there to understand
everything's Crystal Clear she says
you've chosen a certain attitude to the
world around you the fact that this
world might at any moment Fall to Pieces
has a place in this choice in mine it
doesn't that's where we differ geralt
says I'm not sure that's only there
where we differ
the world is falling in ruins she
repeated we can watch it happen and do
nothing or we can counteract it
then Cohen says the world is falling to
ruins how many times have I heard that
me too Lambert grimaced and it's not
surprising it's a popular saying of late
it's what Kings say when it turns out
that a modicum of brains is necessary to
rule after all it's what merchants say
when greed and stupidity have led them
to bankruptcy it's what Wizards say when
they start to lose their influence on
politics or income and the person
they're speaking to should expect some
sort of proposal straight away so cut
the introduction short Tris and present
us with your proposition so it's not
just a role it's the other witchers who
have this view of well you know things
are always messed up people are always
complaining that we're in crisis we
should just focus on our jobs killing
monsters
so Tris says
um you know what I mean you want to hide
your heads in the sand that's your
business but coming from you geralt it's
a great surprise
Tris
Gerald says what do you expect from me
to take an active part in the fight to
save a world which is falling to pieces
am I to enlist in the Army and stop
nilfgaard should I if it comes to
another battle for sod and stand with
you on the hill shoulder to shoulder and
Fight For Freedom I'd be proud she said
quietly lowering her head I'd be proud
and happy to fight at your side and here
geralt is going to tell us something
very important about himself I believe
that
but I'm not Gallant enough not Valiant
enough I'm not suited to be a soldier or
a hero and having an acute fear of pain
mutilation and death is not the only
reason you can't stop a soldier from
being frightened but you can give him
motivation to help him overcome that
fear I have no such motivation I kill
monsters for money I defend children
when their parents pay me to I'm a
Witcher an artificially created mutant
if nilf Guardian parents pay me I'll
defend nilf Guardian children and even
if the world lies in ruin which does not
seem likely to me all carry on killing
monsters in the ruins of this world
until some monster kills me that is my
fate my reason my life and my attitude
to the world it's not what I chose it
was chosen for me
she goes on and she responds and she
says you're embittered or pretending to
be you forget that I know you so don't
play the unfeeling mutant devoid of a
heart of Scruples and of his own free
will in front of me and the reasons for
your bitterness I can guess and
understand series prophecy correct Siri
the child the uh you know person that
geralt gets to claim or who claims him
by the law I'm surprised from the uh
Sentra Kingdom and you know the her
grandmother the Lioness of Centra
um
reorients the life of geralt
imposes a destiny upon him so
um
he says no not correct I see that you
don't know me at all I am afraid of
death just like everyone else but I grew
used to the idea of it very long ago I'm
not under any Illusions I'm not
complaining about fate Tris this is
plain cold calculations statistics no
Witcher has yet died of old age lying in
bed dictating his will not a single one
Siri didn't surprise or frighten me I
know I'm gonna die in some cave which
stinks of carcasses torn apart by a
griffin lamia or Manticore but I don't
want to die in a war because they're not
my Wars
and then she says
I'm surprised at this I'm surprised
you're saying that surprised by your
lack of motivation as you learnedly
chose to describe your supercilious
distance and indifference you were at
sodden angren and trans River you know
what happened to sintra you know what
Bethel Queen kalanth and many thousands
of people there you know the hell Siri
went through why she cries out at night
and I know too because I was also there
I am afraid of pain and death too even
more now than I was then I have good
reason as for motivation it seems to me
back then that I had just as little as
you why should I a magician care about
the fates of sad and bruga sintra or
other kingdoms the problems of having
more or less competent rulers the
interests of merchants and Barons I was
a magician I too could have said it
wasn't my war that I could mix elixirs
for the nilf Guardians on the ruins of
the world but I stood on that Hill next
to vilgafort next to arto Terra Nova
next to Fair cart next to Enid finibar
and Philippa ailhart next to your
yennefer next next to those who no
longer exist Coral Joel venial there was
a moment when out of sheer Terror I
forgot all my spells except for one and
thanks to that spell I could have
teleported myself from that horrible
Place back to my home there was a moment
when I threw up from Fear when Jennifer
and coral held me up on my shoulders and
hair and then Gerald says stop please
stop and she says no I won't and she
goes on and you know narrates it
um and you know he he
truck holds her closer and then she says
they use the highest Magics honest
spells elixirs amules and artifacts
nothing was left wanting for the wounded
Heroes of the hill we were cured patched
up our former appearances returned to us
our hair and sight restored you can
hardly see the marks but I will never
wear a plunging neckline again geralt
never
the witchers said nothing right so then
she says so don't talk to me about
motivation so you know we have a lot of
interesting discussion here and then
Siri pipes up and says I'll stand next
to you right so there's this big moment
of conflict where are people's loyalties
where will their commitments actually
lie and I think it's important that
of the most fruitful discussions in this
take place not just between sparring you
know with this uh misguided person over
here or this one over here but between
geralt and the people who he has love or
friendship with certainly respect
that gets him thinking about where he's
going to eventually commit himself which
he will do I'm actually going to skip
over the discussion with the master
tutor because I I don't want to spend
too much time and jump into the final
book The Time Of content a discontent
contempt I keep on screwing up that that
word and I do want to
um
bring up this this other discussion that
that takes place
so
vilgaforts asked Gerald vilgaforts is
this great Sorcerer And he's geralt is
narrating this to yennefer
why didn't you become a sorcerer Gerald
weren't you ever attracted by the art be
honest I will I was
well then why didn't you follow the
voice of that attraction
I decided it would be wiser to follow
the voice of good sets meaning
years of practice in the witcher's trade
have taught me not to bite off more than
I can chew do you know vilga forts I
once knew a dwarf who has a child
dreamed of being an elf what do you
think would he have become one if he
followed the voice of attraction
vilga Ford says is that supposed to be a
comparison a parallel if so it's utterly
ill judged a dwarf could not become an
elf not without having an elf for its
mother
geralt remained silent for a long time
I get it he finally said I should have
guessed you've been having a root around
in my life history to what purpose if
you don't mind
perhaps said the sorcerer faintly I'm
dreaming of a painting in the gallery of
Glory the two of us seated at a table
and on a brass plaque the title
vilgaforts of rogavin entering into a
pact with geralt of Rivia
that would be an allegory so The Witcher
with the title knowledge triumphing over
ignorance I'd prefer a more realistic
painting entitled in which vilgafort
explains to geralt what this is all
about
and vilgafort says isn't it obvious have
you forgotten the painting I'm dreaming
of hangs in the gallery of Glory where
future Generations who know perfectly
well what's about what event is depicted
in the picture can look at it on the
canvas vilgaforts and geralt are
negotiating and concluding an agreement
as a result of which Gerald following
the voice not some kind of attraction or
predilection but a genuine vocation
finally joined the ranks of Mages this
brings to an end his erstwhile and not
particularly sensible existence which
has no future whatsoever
just think said The Witcher after a
lengthy silence that not so long ago I
believed nothing more could astonish me
believe me vilga forts I'll remember
this banquet in this pageant of
incredible events for a long time worthy
of a painting indeed the title would be
Gerald leaving the Isle of thaned
shaking with laughter and he goes on and
says the causes of our misunderstanding
are clear to me we differ too much to
understand each other you are a mighty
sorcerer from the chapter who has
achieved Oneness with nature I'm a
Wanderer a Witcher a mutant who travels
the world and slays monsters for money
we differ too greatly and the minor fact
that my mother was by accident
was a sorceress is unable to erase that
difference
so we actually do find out in the story
is that his his mother was a sorceress
she in fact at one point heals him in
one of the the uh narratives that that's
going on and then departs as well she
gave him
to the witchers and the witchers did
horrible things to him to make him into
the kind of person that he he is because
that's what is required in order to
produce the sort of person who can fight
monsters and survive most of the young
boys who are given to the witchers don't
actually make it through the process and
interestingly I'll close on this in
the first novel The The Blood of Elves
we do see Siri being brought up she's
not going to be given the herbs and
elixirs and stuff like that but she is
being brought up among the witchers and
effectively being trained for their way
of life but Siri is another story to to
which we need to turn now as another
philosophical theme I think this is
enough of an exploration of Gerald as
arguably the most Central character as
call them the great poll on which the
entire tent of the story is supported
if we find the metaphor compelling that
sapkowski has used to talk about his
storytelling with a circus tent with one
main pole that is geralt as the main
character holding everything up and then
other characters as being the tent pegs
we actually need to modify it as these
stories go on in the first two books we
can say yes that's correct geralt is the
main character but we're going to have
some other very important ones
introduced as the stories go on namely
his good friend dandelion and of course
the love of his life yennefer and then
we're also going to have this character
who begins in the stories as just a
promise
and will become a major main character
as a child going through eventually
becoming arguably an even more main
character by the time we get to the time
of contempt and that is Siri
we also do have one other character Tris
Marigold who will play a significant
role as well and maybe what we want to
say is
yes it starts out as a circus tent with
just one pole but then we find that the
tent pegs turn into pulls of their own
and the tent gets much larger a place
where we can do more see more witness
more and I'm just going to run sort of
sequentially through all of these and
not talking about Tris so much just in
interest of time so the very first thing
I want to bring up
is what happens towards the end of the
story that has to do with uh Queen
kalanth and her court and pavetta and
and Dooney so kalanth uh is is you know
telling geralt to forgive and then
Dooney says ask again what do you ask
for and Gerald says
in order to become a Witcher you have to
be born in the shadow of Destiny and
very few are born like that that's why
there are so few of us we're growing old
dying without anyone to pass our
knowledge our gifts onto we lack
successors and this world is full of
evil which waits for the day none of us
are left and so he you know asks you
know for the uh
object you could say of the law of
surprise and he's going to show up once
a child has been born and claimed that
child we'll come back to that in a bit
so the next passage to look at has to do
with um talking with dandelion who's now
joined the The Witcher on some of his
adventures and dandelion is a Bard he is
a troubadour a singer he takes the
stories that are halfway true turns them
into song makes them bigger than life
and spreads the uh the story of The
Witcher as well as so many other stories
far and wide and he's a very roguish guy
right he's always getting in trouble
with one person or another uh he has
love affairs which turn out badly and as
it turns out he and Gerald are caught up
by this band of elves and we're going to
talk a little bit about that Dynamic a
little bit later on in this and he shows
that he can have a certain kind of
Courage as well
jeral tells the elves spare dandelion at
at least not out of lofty Mercy out of
Common Sense and you know the elves say
um you know if he survives thanks to you
he'll undoubtedly feel obliged to
Avenger and dandelion says you can be
sure of that you can be sure of that you
son of a kill me too because I
promise otherwise I'll set the world
against you you'll see what lies from a
fur coat can do we'll finish you off
even if we have to level these mountains
of yours to the ground you can be sure
of that and then Gerald says how stupid
you are dandelion and he says your
mother gives birth to you only once and
only once do you die
the the poet said heartily the effects
on what's spoiled by his teeth rattling
like Castanet so he's willing to throw
himself in with the Witcher completely
even though he is in fact afraid
um there's some you know other
interesting things coming up lady
Jennifer will come in in an adventure
where uh dandelion has been uh injured
in fact but magically and so geralt uh
brings him to yennefer
and we get this interesting description
um
the woman sat up scrambling out of the
bed closed she had pretty shoulders
shapely neck and around and a black
velvet choker with a star-shaped Jewel
sparkling with diamonds apart from the
choker she had nothing on so clearly
she's not into modesty she's kind of
above that thank you she took the mug
from his hand drank greedily uh who are
you asked the black-haired woman
narrowing her eyes and covering herself
what are you doing here and where damn
it is barant her servant and he says
well which question shall I answer first
he immediately regretted the sarcasm the
woman raised her hand in a golden streak
shout out from her fingers geralt
reacted instinctively Crossing both
hands in the sign of heliotrope and
caught the spell it just in front of his
face but the discharge was so strong it
threw him back against the wall
no need he shouted saying the woman
raised her hand again lady Jennifer I
come in peace with no evil intentions
and then she says well who are you and
he says I'm geralt of Rivia a Witcher
and she says how did you get in here and
for what reason and then she says a
Witcher not not only is it the first one
I've seen up close but it's none other
than the famous white wolf right so
they're encountering each other for the
first time and he says yennefer I rode
non-stop all day from rind I waited at
night for the gates to open I gave your
doorman who didn't want to let me in a
Blow To The Head I Disturbed your sleep
and peace just courtesy and importantly
all because my friend needs help which
only you can give him give it to him
please and then if you like we can talk
about mutations and aberrations and what
is it well his friend has an injury to
his throat larynx and vocal cords and
injury caused by a Scarlet Mist so you
know they
Converse a little bit more and a little
bit later
what we're going to find is another
engagement right she asks him to come by
and here's a very interesting Passage
this tells us something about uh
sorceresses and mages and people like
that
each to their own taste but in actual
fact not many would describe sorceresses
as good looking indeed all of them came
from Social Circles where they only fate
for daughters would be marriage who
would have thought of condemning their
daughter to years of tedious studies and
the tortures of somatic mutations if she
could be given it away in marriage and
advantageously Allied who wished to have
a Sorceress in their family despite the
the respect enjoyed by magicians a
sorceress's family did not benefit from
her in the least Because by the time the
girl had completed her education nothing
tied her to her family anymore only
Brotherhood counted to the exclusion of
all else so daughters with no chance of
finding a husband became sorceresses
unlike priestesses and druidices who
only unwillingly took an uglier crippled
girls sorceresses Sorcerers took anyone
who showed evidence of a predisposition
If the child passed the first years of
training magic entered into the equation
straightening and evening out legs
repairing bones which had badly knitted
patching hair lips removing scars
birthmarks and pox scars the young
sorceress would become attractive
because The Prestige of her profession
demanded it the result was pseudo-pretty
women with the angry and cold eyes of
ugly girls girls who couldn't forget
their ugliness had been covered over by
the mask of magic only for The Prestige
of their profession so this is you know
quite an interesting uh
thing to say and this is going to be
part of the story of yennefer now
towards the end of this first book in
the last of the stories there's a wish
that goes on and Gerald has these wishes
and uh Jennifer has been trying to you
know conquer this this gin in order to
get it and she tells him
you've still got one last wish haven't
you make it you'll free the gin and I'll
bottle it and then uh uh you know what
is the wish she tells him the wish hurry
up Terrell what do you desire
immortality riches Fame power might
privileges hurry we haven't any time
humanity she said suddenly smiling
nastily I've guessed haven't I that's
what you want that's what you dream of
of release of the freedom to be who you
want not who you have to be the gin will
fulfill that wish geralt just say it
he stayed silent she stood over him in
the flickering Radiance of the Wizard's
fear and the glow of magic amidst the
flashes of rays restraining the Gin
streaming hair and eyes blazing Violet
erect slender dark terrible and
beautiful all of a sudden she leaned
over and looked him in the eyes he
caught the scent of lilac and
gooseberries you're not saying anything
she has so what is it you desire Witcher
what is your most hidden dream what is
it you don't know is it that you don't
know or you can't decide look for it
within yourself look deeply and
carefully because I swear by the force
you won't get another chance like this
suddenly he knew the truth he knew it he
knew what she used to be what she
remembered what she couldn't forget what
she lived with who she really was before
she had become a sorceress
her cold penetrating angry Wise Eyes
Were that of a hunchback he was
horrified no not of the truth he was
horrified that she could read his
thoughts find out what he had guessed
that she would never forgive him for it
he deadened that thought within himself
killed it through it from his memory
Forever Without a Trace feeling as he
did so an enormous relief feeling that
and then suddenly The Witcher understood
what it was that he wanted and he made
his wish
now
a little bit later she says that wish of
yours I heard what you wished for I was
astounded simply astounded I've expected
anything but to what made you do it
geralt why
why me don't you know
she leaned over him touched him he felt
her hair smelling of lilac and
gooseberries brush his face suddenly he
knew he'd never forget that scent that
soft touch knew he'd never be able to
compare it with any other scent or touch
Jennifer kissed him and he understood
he'd never desire any lips other than
hers so soft and moist sweet with
lipstick he knew that from that moment
only she would exist her neck shoulders
and breasts freed from her black dress
her delicate cool skin which couldn't be
compared to any other he had touched he
gazed into her violent eyes the most
beautiful eyes in the world eyes which
he feared would become
everything he knew
your wish she whispered I don't know
whether such a wish can be ever
fulfilled I don't know whether there's
such a force in nature that could
fulfill such a wish but if there is then
you've condemned yourself condemned
yourself to me
so
they now are are connected together uh
geralt actually will sleep with some
other people including Chris but
um you know Jennifer is in a certain
sense his his Destiny and he hers we
have you know another nice connection
between them uh talked about it here in
sort of Destiny
um you know it was very interesting
scene that that's uh developed here and
she tells him about a winter Queen and
about The Witcher uh you know the wild
Hunt and stuff like that and she says
there's no romance in you and I I like
Elven Legends they're so captivating
what do pity humans don't have any
Legends like that perhaps one day they
will perhaps they'll create some but
what would human Legends deal with
all around where everyone looks there's
grayness and dullness even things which
begin beautifully lead swiftly to
boredom and dreariness to that human
ritual that weary some Rhythm called
life oh geralt it's not easy being a
sorceress but comparing it to mundane
human existence and then he falls asleep
a little bit later on we have another uh
engagement between them
and she says um
here we go
Gerald yes yeah now you answer my
question the question I've never asked
you the one I've always feared I won't
ask it you at this time either but
answer it because I greatly desire to
hear your answer it's the one word the
only word you've never told me utter It
Gerald please
I cannot Yen why not you don't know he
smiled sadly my answer would just be a
word a word which doesn't Express a
feeling doesn't Express an emotion
because I'm bereft of them a word which
would be nothing but the sound you make
when you strike a cold empty skull
she says no Gerald that's not the truth
or perhaps it is but not the whole truth
you aren't bereft of feeling now I see
it now I know you complete the sentence
yeah and you've decided don't lie I know
you I can see it in your eyes
give me your hand she said she took his
hand between hers at once and he felt a
tingling and the pulsing of the blood in
the veins of his forearm
she engages in creational Magic the most
elevated accomplishment among Sorcerers
she creates two kestrels two black
kestrels and she says I'm going to need
them both how wrong I was geralt to what
an error the vanity of the Ice Queen
convinced of her omnipotence has brought
me for there are some things which there
is no way of obtaining even by Magic and
there are gifts which may not be
accepted if one is unable to reciprocate
them with something equally precious
otherwise such a gift will slip through
the fingers melt Like A Shard of ice
gripped in the hand then only regret the
sense of loss and hurt will remain I am
a sorceress geralt the power over matter
which I possess as a gift a reciprocated
gift for it I paid with everything I
possessed nothing remained I was
mistaken she repeated but I shall
correct my mistake emotions and feelings
emotions whims and lies Fascinations and
games feelings and their absence gifts
which may or may not be accepted lies
and Truth what is truth the negation of
lies or the statement of a fact and if
the fact is a lie then what is the truth
who is full of feelings which torment
them and who is the empty karapas of a
cold skull who what is truth geralt what
is the essence of Truth and he says I
don't know yet and tell me no she said
and lowered her eyes no I cannot draw
alt I cannot tell you that that bird
begotten from the touch of your hand
will tell you bird what is the essence
of truth truth the Kestrel said Is A
Shard of ice and so we have this very
interesting discourse as these
characters are figuring out their own
relation not just to their own pasts and
their Destinies but to each other
uh we go on and we find that geralt
encounters Siri here he encounters her
first uh in you know not quite realizing
who she is saves her and
um she tells him
my mother was a witch so you'd better
watch your step my papa was enchanted
too it was all told to be my by one of
my nannies and when Grandma found out
about it there was a dreadful to do
because I'm destined you know to do what
I don't know Siri said intently but I'm
destined that's what my nanny said and
grandma said she won't let anyone the
whole Ruddy Castle will collapse first
do you understand and nanny has said
that nothing nothing at all can help
with Destiny ha and then Nanny wept and
Grandma yelled do you see I'm destined I
won't be the wife of that silly Kirsten
geralt he said and so he tells her go to
sleep and uh you know they're with the
dryads she doesn't want to to you know
remain with the dryads who would turn
her into one and uh then later on we
find in uh you know Siri
um talking with with geralt again
um and they're slowly figuring out that
they are actually going to be destined
for each other and they they are in a
very important way there's a interesting
confrontation between kalanth her
grandmother who wants to conceal her
from Gerald and
um
Kalan says The Witcher is now returned
after six years as agreed you know and
they talk about the storytellers and the
lies that are going to be involved with
this and then she says
um
I've been reading up on all of this
stuff since pavetta's child is the
chance of becoming a Witcher I went to
Great pains my sources geralt reveal
nothing however regarding how many
children intend withstand the trial of
the grasses would you like to satisfy my
curiosity in this and Gerald says you
know that Mike the code and my oath
forbid me from even uttering that name
much less discussing it and then she
says well what I've learned is three
Atmos four and ten uh survive first the
choice and then the trials and then the
changes how many youngsters ultimately
receive medallions and silver swords one
in ten one in 20.
and she says you know I've pondered long
over this and I've come to the
conclusion the selection of the children
at the stage of the choice has scanned
significance what difference does it
make in the end geralt which child dies
or goes insane stuff full of Narcotics
which did what difference does it make
whose brain bursts from hallucinations
whose eyes rupture and gush forth
instead of becoming Cat's Eyes what
difference does it make whether the
child Destiny chose or an utterly chance
one dies in its own blood and puke
answer me
and he says what's the point of this are
you expecting an answer and she says no
you know I I didn't expect that from you
and
it turns out that he he realizes that
you know he's he's being played uh and
then the law of surprise is you know
going to be Central here and she says
are all stories about the law of
surprise myths yes it's hard to call an
accident Destiny but you witchers do not
stop searching no we don't but it's
senseless nothing has any point do you
believe a child of Destiny will pass
through the trials without danger and
Harry says something very important we
believe such a child would not require
the trials
so she goes on and says
there is no better way to pass on
hereditary traits than the natural way
you went through the trials and survived
so if you need a child with special
qualities and endurance why don't you
find a woman who I'm tackless aren't I
but I think I've guessed and as it turns
out witchers are sterile so Siri is
going to be trained to be a Witcher and
we find this In The Blood of Elves at
the start Tris Marigold you know is is
traveling runs into Siri right and Siri
is being brought up as a sort of Witcher
in training she's being bruised all the
time she's learning Sword Play she's
studying things and she's also got some
clear magical abilities and so
interestingly what we're going to find
is that Tris will say you you've got to
cultivate her in different ways she is a
girl after all right and and she has
magical abilities so you can't just make
her into a Witcher and what we're going
to find is that Siri is going to become
more and more and more of a main
character from The Blood of Elves onward
I'm only going to bring up in an
interest of time a few passages from
this and the following one yennefer and
Siri have a conversation about magic
that's particularly important and it
it's quite long so I may summarize parts
of this
yennefer says magic is in some people's
opinion the embodiment of chaos it's a
key capable of opening the Forbidden
door the door behind which lurk
nightmares fear and unimaginable Horrors
behind which enemies hide in weight
destructive Powers the forces of Pure
Evil capable of annihilating not only
the one who opens the door but with them
the entire world
and since there's no lack of those who
try to open the door someone at some
point is going to make a mistake and
then the destruction of the world will
be for judged and inevitable magic is
therefore the revenge and the weapon of
chaos the fact is following the
conjunction of the Spheres people have
learned to use Magic
is the curse and undoing of the world
the undoing of mankind and that's how it
is Siri those who believe that magic is
chaos are not mistaken
so that's one point of view on magic
magic Jennifer continued after a while
is in some people's opinion art great
elitist art capable of creating
beautiful and extraordinary things magic
is a talent granted to only a chosen few
others deprived of talent can only look
at the results of artists works with
admiration and envy can admire the
finished work while feeling that without
these creations and without this Talent
the world would be a poorer place the
fact that following the conjunction to
the Spheres some Chosen Few discovered
talent and Magic within themselves the
fact that they found art within
themselves is a blessing of beauty and
that's how it is those who believe that
magic is Art is also right so now we've
got two different perspectives on Magic
and then she gives another one
there are also those according to whom
magic is a science in order to master it
talent and innate ability are not enough
years of keen study and arduous work are
essential endurance and self-discipline
are necessary magic acquired like this
is Knowledge Learning the limits of
which are constantly stretched by
enlightened and vigorous Minds by
experience experiments and practice
magic acquired in such a way as progress
it is the plow the loom the water bill
the smelting furnace the winch and the
pulley it is progress Evolution change
it is constant movement upwards towards
Improvement towards the Stars the fact
that following the conjunction of the
sphere as we discovered magic will one
day allow us to reach the Stars
those who consider magic to be a science
are also right
remember that Siri and now come to me
remember magic is chaos Art and Science
it is a curse a blessing and a progress
it depends on who uses magic how they
use it and to what purpose and Magic is
everywhere all around us easily
accessible so she's
engaging in kind of an info dump about
the world a very important lesson that
shows us the depth of yennefer's
intellect and her willingness to pass
things on in some ways unselfishly to
Siri and you know geralt
uh Siri his daughter of sorts yennefer
become kind of a family don't they along
with Tris and uh dandelion as you might
say younger brother younger sister being
all connected in some kind of destined
unit I'll just bring up uh two or three
other things
there is a beautiful uh you know love
scene between them which is not
pornographic at all and it's quite
romantic without being sappy I'll just
read one line of this uh that sapkowski
has in here
um
they found one another conquered Their
Fear and a moment later found the truth
which exploded under their eyelids with
a terrible blind and Clarity tore apart
the lips pursed in determination with a
moan the time shuddered spasmodically
and froze everything vanished and touch
became the only functioning sense what a
wonderful description now immediately
after that yennefer says
you want to build a home
geralt was quiet he was angry with
himself as if he as he had been thinking
for her he'd accidentally allowed her to
read a thought about himself herself a
pretty dream said Jennifer stroking him
lightly on the shoulder a home a house
built with your own hands and you and I
in that house you would keep horses and
sheep and I would have a little garden
cook food and card wool which we would
take to market with the pennies earned
from selling the wood in various crops
we would buy what we needed let's say
some copper cauldrons in an iron rake
every now and then Siri would visit with
her husband and three children and tris
Marigold would occasionally look into
stay for a few days we'd grow old
together beautifully and with dignity
and should I ever get bored you could
play for me in the evening on your
homemade bagpipes playing the bagpipes
as everyone knows is the best remedy for
depression this is not a life available
for them but you know they they have
something else as well now this uh the
time of contempt ends with Siri having
escaped in from this and this and this
and this and survived eventually joining
this band of robbers called the rats and
we get a long description of the
different members of the gang
they were Outcast they were a strange
mixed bag created by War Misfortune and
contempt War Misfortune and contempt had
brought them together and thrown them
onto the bank in the way that a river in
flood throws and deposits drifting black
pieces of wood smoothed by Stones onto
its bank and they fight against all the
different peoples and patrols and things
like that
um here's another description
they didn't take long to find each other
in the merry crowd too much
distinguished them they had too much in
common they were United by their love of
gaudy colorful fanciful Outlets of
stolen trinkets beautiful horses and
swords which they didn't even unfasten
when they danced they stood out because
of their arrogance and conceit over
confidence mocking truculence and
impetuousness and their contempt they
were children of the time of contempt
and they had nothing but contempt for
others for them only Force mattered
skill at wielding weapons which they
quickly acquired on the High Roads
resoluteness Swift hordes horses and
sharp swords and companions comrades
mates because the one who is alone will
perish from Hunger from the sword from
the arrow from makeshift peasant clubs
in from The Noose or in flames
so uh
they become a band of rats uh and you
know then who joins them
until the day a pale hair taciturned
girl as Angela's an acrobat appeared a
girl about the about whom the rats knew
nothing aside from the fact that she was
as they had once been like each one of
them lonely and full of bitterness
bitterness for what the time of contempt
had taken from her and in times of
contempt anyone who is alone must perish
Jizzle her Kaylee Reef Israel missile
Assa Assa and falca the prefect of
Amarula was inordinately astonished when
he learned that the rats were now
operating as a gang of seven
and the book ends with a soldier talking
about running into the seventh and a
discussion about looking for this girl
looking for Siri who's who's being you
know uh there's rewards offered for her
she has joined the rats she has become
one of them and that is where this last
well the fourth book ends and the rest
of the novels begin but that's enough
for this you see how important these
other characters do become we're no
longer just a circus tent with one main
pole we have yennefer just as important
in many respects as geralt we have
dandelion his close friend and companion
we have Tris Marigold and we have at the
center of everything by the end
Siri
as is proving so often the case we're
not going to get to every one of the
philosophical themes I had originally
intended to talk about we consumed a lot
of time going through passages in the
books and there's you know no bad part
about that except for the fact that
we're not going to talk about one of the
big themes that I had I've mentioned
already but wanted to go much further
into that is the rivalries and tensions
between all the different races of
hominids on the continent but good news
is we will talk about that perhaps in
the follow-up session right after this
video finishes premiering and we'll
definitely talk about it the next time
around that we go into The Witcher
Universe which will be definitely
happening next year in the worlds of
speculative fiction series as we go
through the four remaining novels one of
which is a prequel talking about The
Witcher series what I do want to say as
we close this up is this entire Witcher
series and sapkowski's oov as a you know
totality is something that was suggested
by fans of the worlds of speculative
fiction series I'm always a little
skeptical a little bit hesitant this
time the recommendation as has been so
often the case with many of the previous
authors turned out to be really quite
wonderful and so to all of you who voted
for subkowski's Witcher back when we
were you know polling and voting about
who we ought to do next in Worlds of
speculative fiction let me just say
thank you and I'm going to leave off
here and hope that you'll join me for
future sessions where we're going to
cover many other great authors in
speculative fiction and eventually come
around to sapowski's Witcher series
again
thank you